tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vigente ed oggi siamo in un
videogame stranissimo però dovrebbe
essere epico
si chiama ragazzi let's play simulator
2016 porchera se non riesco a mettere a
posto la sedia li mortacci mi ha
attratto c'è scritto qui all gol è il
tuo obiettivo è quello di crescere fino
ad arrivare ad un milione di iscritti
sul tuo canale di a cube che dovrebbe
essere tipo youtube solo che non
potevano mettere youtube e ricordati se
raggiungi 0 dollari non l'ex play forio
quindi devi anche raggiungere i big
money dio che news street
io non c'ho twitter quindi io già ho
perso a prescindere [ __ ] di sempre
che si può partire giorno 1 ragazzi
iscritti al canale il 50 siamo partiti
con 50 iscritti non si sa come 35
dollari di budget fantastico e una pizza
sul tavolo meglio della partenza mia
solita capsula webcam mi sembra ovvio
vuoi fare l'ex play john j sola bombs
new strategy fiction 2 il cazzo è
fiction mi sembra un gioco schifo si
spera facciamolo magari piace a questa
gameplay che bello nuovi iscritti in
arrivo c'è grandissimo è la madonna 70
iscritti e grazie a questi sono i
messaggi dei fan come quando voi vi
consiglia tv giochi da fare fantastico
amoled e terroristi
ma che bello questo gameplay bello è
vinta ma tom ha rigato so più di pai non
sono sicuro del perché sta leggendo
questo ma magari poi recensire il nuovo
hot sexy far pg chiamato ecstasy giallo
questo invece non lo voglio fare se non
lo voglio fare e ho perso iscritti ovvio
compensi che c'è la gente stavano sul
computer dire cazzo perché non fa quel
gioco mi sto disi scrivendo come si suol
dire è morto un iscritto se ne fa un
altro credo od altro che siete e twitter
aria quindi ma che cazzo mi fa twittare
sul serio ma come grazie non ce l'ho
twitter grazie però per aver chiesto due
o tre consigli per registrare che tuo
zio fa vitali da il primo eleva lo sto
cazzo di gatto dal monitor cortesia
secondo consiglio cambia webcam gesù
santo terzo consiglio ma che cazzo è
quello mixer o una tastiera che c'hai
livelli casa 6 hardware cambia pizza
perché magari quelle un po marcia poi io
parlo parlo ma con cazzo che parlo che
cioè i fazzoletti pieni di m
anche i nets mobile game from rovio va
bene proviamo lo bello questo gioco che
ci sono i fantasmini che mi fanno schifo
il cazzo mi chiedo 180 iscritti
porca [ __ ] job sarri se ti chiami
bisenzio tar
io non ti leggo la mail a prescindere
chiamati piuttosto calogero ma non
bethesda dar puoi fare l'ex play del
nostro bimbo nord e red famoso fps bello
michele grafica ho fatto la madonna
quanti iscritti 200 ciclisti demone in
com più 16 grazie quadretto 16 dollari
cioè i big money siamo passati da 35
dollari al 39 posso comprarmi le big
bubble sports olympic champion che cazzo
me ne frega a me di champion olimpiche
faccio youtuber ma [ __ ] games bar
per la città che lui anch'io ha detto la
stessa cosa più o meno spammer fare un
l'ex play sulle splace molecole vedere
quanti iscritti italiano con pesi a
questa sarebbe praticamente sarebbe
amnesia solo che hanno cambiato il nome
lo ha chiamato compresi
se fai amnesia bambini ma voglio 300
iscritti con annette ma minimo ma quanto
cazzo ha fatto che avevo detto io che a
me serafico il community seppi nicevic
siamo arrivati a mille iscritti ragazzi
speciale del gameplay mi scuso se lo
speciale non era così pieno ma ho
giocato a tanti giochi e non sapevo
quali scegliere per lo speciale la
prossima volta ci lavora un po di più
buffa arc sarebbe fifa si facciamo fifa
che i giochi di calcio portano ma quello
non era un gioco di calcio al gioco di
macchine qualcosa province sono arrivata
a 2000 a 2500 iscritti non due giorni
pixar ter che sarebbe kickstarter your
kickstarter campaigning wealth of place
to day poi tuttora mila iscritti in un
giorno e mezzo raccomandato del cazzo
cielo targa di youtube ma senza tremila
iscritti la targa si prendono 100.000
che cazzo di sarebbe questa che non è
proprio c'è simile più o meno solo che
io l'ho preso a 100.000 non a 3000
raccomandato di merda ciao sono due tipi
un famoso l'ex player
voglio fare un video con te porca
[ __ ] in un giorno faccio 40 milioni
di iscritti subito subito zio 820 ma se
ne ha 40 milioni di iscritti
popolazioni del canada come cassano
presa 820 piaceva così forte che non
potevi neanche sentir ti va bene hai
guadagnato un po di iscritti 829 hai mai
sentito nel nostro fps chiamato mordor
lance la terra di merda l'amore è un
gioco fps bene in realtà pensavo fosse
la madonna non è una bella cera vai a
dormire
mica quanto ci capisci cazzo anche io
ragazzino nave l'asma vado a dormire vi
lascio così pes razzano da il suo te
prego ma metti un po che va di nove
normali ma chiamati pippo siamo per
rinviare shrink un fantastico gioco
d'azione vuoi farci wesley famoso l'ex
lei mi sembra zio fester che gli sta
uscendo il ginocchio dal dal ginocchio
più 666 satan a conferma jeremy school
boy è un mio compagno di classe ciao
oggi il mio ultimo giorno di scuola
spero di vederti di jeremy ciao jeremy
mi dispiace ma devo fare video su get
mario che un bel gioco che mi hanno
consigliato vorrei esserci ma credo che
mi divertirò di più a giocare anche
mario è misto nuovo gioco fps si chiama
boom
ok giochiamo mi dovevo andare a scuola
che ce la sto che rischiano di jeremy
che era l'ultimo giorno quando il cazzo
di scritti ho fatto in un giorno 10 mila
iscritti e vai quei momenti epici dei
videogames 2
anche questa volta mi scuso se è durato
poco c'è la mia mamma che aveva
preparato i carciofi e non potevo stare
a montare il t tell bier soling stiamo
facendo
peter beer solid un gioco action lo vuoi
fare ha voglia mi capitarvi a soli
perché hideo kojima ti contatta per fare
metal gear ma sono convintissimo 6.600
iscritti non li fa neanche più di pai
6.600 iscritti al giorno di questi file
del quarto giorno li fa gioco horror o
fuori e ho già jack e horror va bene
quindi cos'è un incrocio tra de grace
lander ho perso iscritti perché dopo
quella merda di ufo riario kiuva sospeso
il tuo canale per un po di tempo ai
presso iscritti perché cazzo sono
vietati giochi horror ma da quando
adesso faccio coma questo va bene è
sempre quello e il gioco [ __ ] eva è
sempre quello però salotto guadagnato 5
mila iscritti come cazzo è possibile
star game star gaming vedere morirà
famiglia di cirrosi epatica al fegato 4
misto gioco che mi ricorda un sacchi
simo sixty seconds quello che facevo nel
bunker bellissimo your bit coinvolgere o
che bella bitcoin mi hanno dato un po di
dollari tipo 42 solo 200 dollari che
cazzo di biglie scheda video della mia
nonna sqlite3 confidenziale ciao sono
niebel duel sei stato scelto per
l'esclusiva accesso demo di puck life 3
vorresti giocare al gioco va bene
giochiamo perchè non mi faccio i care sì
perché non lo fermi perché non mi fa
piacere si e non lo facciamo perché non
me lo ha fatto fare ragazzi al flash lo
aspetta tutto il mondo avrei fatto tipo
14 milioni di iscritti ma cosa che merda
è questa non mi piace volevo fare quello
di prima va bene così va bene così
scherzavo facciamoli sti giochi che sono
belli come si chiama facciamo lo
facciamo zio league of legends giochiamo
a league of legends che alla gente gli
piace league of legends ovvio che hanno
fatto fidare trina vero fatto una
partita de merda con e isa ma un
messaggio da una fan leggiamo ciao sono
samantha se non smette di giocare a
questi giorni stupidi
me ne vado insomma sono anni
insomma no no sta matta samantha fatta
mi spiace ragazzi non posso versare a
samantha perché devo fare gli iscritti
tanti quindi io vado avanti e sono quasi
centomila non ci posso credere mai ma
castings breed vuol dire mocassini di
razza che non ha senso però fatto 14mila
iscritti la tua ragazza è la tua ragazza
ott
vabbè grazie a federica la tua ragazza
si è fatta accidentalmente vedere in
live streaming mentre indossava un lince
reina ma brutta [ __ ]
mica udienza quindi ho fatto gli
iscritti a caso ho fatto mille iscritti
frega se volete vedere la gente costa
mano o andate suo amico o su chat
roulette oppure sui un altro che almeno
16.000 iscritti
porca [ __ ] 100mila iscritti
fantastico ragazzi siamo arrivati a
cento km vr ingraziare mia nonna
l'aragosta e lo champagne e con 100 mila
ragazzi siamo arrivati a 100.000 non
posso che ringraziarvi per questo
incredibile traguardo la sciara la sla
tanto magari prendo subito dovete rita
non ha immediatamente maledetti muro ma
scherzavo della regalo ci giochiamo a
questo l'ex play ha voglia che ci
giochiamo
porca [ __ ] quanto fatto spider flutes
golf che famiglia e per la madonna ai 21
con successo il tuo costume da yoda
d'infanzia che da piccolo mi vestivo
dall'oda su ebay
grazie a 550 dollari perché che manco
fosse fatto con la vera pelle di yoda la
madonna come ho guadagnato di più
vendendo il mio costume la d'infanzia
che coi costi video su back to back up
becca grazie giu becker qui tuoi
messaggi spirituali profondi mi mi
serviva tantissimo chi noemi descritto
fa 3 300 mila foto ha raggiunto i 42 mi
piace su insta pana ram e ho guadagnato
iscritti perché ragazzi siamo su spike
traffic che sarebbe minecraft deve
andare bene ma che questo faccia sempre
iscritti di far mancare niente
l'unica è questo per un gioco fantasy va
che king fa minecraft fi scritti a caso
la madonna attenzione ragazzi siamo
arrivati a mezzo milioni di iscritti
dopo un secolo e mezzo dai kyoto ragazzi
che un credo che l'episodio perché siamo
arrivati a metà nel prossimo cercherò di
arrivare al milione siamo arrivati a
mezzo milione da qui in poi diventa
difficile qui ha concluso che l'episodio
ragazzi spero che vi do vi sia piaciuto
e cosa piuttosto tuo commento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook con ivy
adottata una descrizione stasera city
iscrivetevi e devono essere 30.000
almeno di quelli di oggi sono riusciti
scatena ci vediamo al prossimo vinto
dalle ragazze